I think that for me I'm really big on
vulnerability Selena Gomez standing by
her words after sharing these all
natural picks
I'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
I be better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger yep cell goes makeup free in
her latest Instagram post I love it
alongside the fresh-faced shots a simple
one-word caption me I'm very honest
though in general Celine is known for
her refreshing Candor like when she
posted this makeup tutorial on Tick Tock
[Music]
the clip gained lots of attention with
Minnie pointing out her shaking hands
and in a sense deleted comment she
responded quote LOL I shake because of
my medication for Lupus Selena Gomez was
diagnosed with lupus depression and
anxiety
Selena opened up about her lupus
diagnosis in her documentary my mind and
me let me make a promise
I am going to stop living like this I
just want the free show how do I learn
how to Breeze my own Breath Again
everything that was happening in her
life was free reign with the exception
she was very I think she was very
sensitive about
not
necessarily having
her sister in the dark there was a level
of
um sensitivity to that and I was also
very sensitive to the fact that some of
her friends didn't want to be filmed in
a weird way I feel like it is it's a
time capsule of a period of my life
where I look back and I actually feel
bad for my that version of myself and I
I think that it was good for me to see
how I was responding to my body the way
I was acting the way it was so
irrational at moments and I think it was
really healing for me to see that and
get it out I think
foreign
[Music]